tape Britain is run by people who seem
to hate the collection in their care and
keep insulting the artists whose work
they are meant to be preserving for
future Generations most notably Tate
Britain has closed the Rex Whistler
mural room insulted Rex Whistler who
died fighting the Nazis who insulted
Stanley Spencer and degraded him as some
kind of racist I think that all of the
people in charge of the collection of
tape written should be fired I think
they have no right to be in charge of a
great National Collection but that's the
difference that seems to exist today
there was a period where to be on a
board like that of Tate of Britain was
to know that you had a guardianship for
a short time of one of the great
collections in the country and indeed in
the world it takes a certain type of
extraordinary not just hubris but a kind
of arrogance to dare to think that your
job is not to preserve the collection
but to stand in judgment over